good evening everybody
and welcome councillor durham thank you
good evening and welcome to this
strategy resources committee meeting on
thursday the 15th of july
my name is councillor richard sidor and
i'm chairman of the committee
the first item before we continue is
chairman's notices
and just to go through some housekeeping
issues
members the meeting is set up and
designed to mitigate for covid
therefore can i ask all of you present
to work within the protocols
agreed by council in the interest of
both members and
officers we are streaming live as well
as recording
and by being present in the meeting you
are giving your consent
to be recorded members and officers
during each item
please put your hand up or wave your
paddle
to indicate if you wish to speak and i
will try to
make sure that i notice everybody
at the appropriate time
i think it probably is yeah
drinks all round
please reference a page number or
paragraph movement referring to agenda
papers
and keep your contribution as clear and
concise as possible
and ensure your microphones remain off
when not speaking
as we are limited in terms of numbers
that can be in the chamber
that was a sequel we will have to manage
the logistics
of the officers attending for the
various agenda items
therefore we may have to pause between
agenda items
whilst that occurs finally can i draw
your attention to the notice on the
agenda papers regarding different levels
within the chamber and advise you that
the fire exit is behind
me so we move on to
item number two which is apologies for
absence uh tara may have the apologies
please yes thank you chairman apologies
been received from councillor boyce
council mrs chino councillor jarvis
and councillor keys attending as a
substitute for council mrs channel thank
you chairman
thank you very much tara so we now move
on to
item number three which is the minutes
of the meeting held on the 15th of june
2021 these can be found on pages 5-20
and i would ask them to be approved as a
true and accurate record
i so move do i have a second to please
thank you councillor swain
if any members wishes to raise any
matter of accuracy
they need to indicate they wish to speak
councillor thompson
no that's fine um
okay
okay
thank you very much council thompson uh
councillor stamp yeah thank you chair
just that i'm a member of essex county
council i don't think there's anything
on towards today chairman so i don't
think there's anything to declare
all right thank you
for openness and transparency chairman
i'll also declare a member
same reason thank you very much cancer
durham
so that was my next so can we agree
those by ascent or take a vote does that
go by a sense
yeah thank you members so so you did
jump ahead councillor stan
[Laughter]
so we move on to um agenda item four
which is disclosure of interest
and that is to disclose the existence of
uh a nature of any disposable cunery
or other pecuniary or non-pecuniary
interest relating to items on the agenda
having regard to paragraph
68 inclusive of the code of conduct
apart from council dharma are there any
other
interests okay thank you very much
members
so we now move on to agenda item five
which is public participation
and i can advise that we have no
receiving no submissions
i am aware of your request to see you're
not a member of the public counsellor
so we now move on to agenda item six
which is year end treasury out turn 2020
to 21
found on pages 21 to 32
and i'll hand over to mr leslie director
resources and mr
porteous to present this particular
report
okay so this report sets out the
council's treasury management activity
for the year 2021
and is required to be reported under
treasury management code of practice
during the year the council had an
average of around 22 million
invested and at the end of the year
investment stood at
21 million slightly up from the 19
million at the start of the year
around uh half of that that's 10 million
of the investments at the end of the
year were with other local authorities
on a short-term basis
returns across all investments averaged
1.09 percent with the council's property
uh fund providing the highest level of
returns at 4.2 percent
appendix 2 shows the council complied
with its prudential indicators around
security and liquidity of investments
and that it has no borrowing requirement
thank you mr leslie so the
recommendation as set out in the report
as
follows that members review the treasury
out return report for compliance
purposes
do i have a second to please thank you
councillor swain
i now invite members to make any
comments on the report
any comments at all
that's an easy one then uh so uh
i will now ask uh can we agree this uh
via ascent which i presume we will be
able to
agree thank you very much
uh so now move on to agenda item seven
which is the provisional financial
outcome
uh pages 20 21 page i'm sorry year 20 20
to 21
pages 33 to 43 and again i'll ask
mr leslie metasports to present the
report
so the position is good news in the
sense that there is an underspender
being reported despite the impact of
kovid
the out turn position is still subject
to audit however and the audit is
currently underway
the actual impact of covid itself
is broadly the same as that reported
back in november time
although overspends on the leisure
contract and waste collection are
actually lower than expected
although this has been offset by a
reduction in
planning development fees however
income losses are eligible for the
income compensation
why expenditure isn't which does mean
that switch between the two and the fact
that the finance team have
gone through in detail the losses which
are eligible
for the income compensation scheme means
that there is an additional
amount of income compensation grant uh
to that that was previously reported in
november
we reported one million from that grant
scheme in november
and we are now looking at claiming 1.4
million
back from that scheme because of the
reasons outlined
table 3 on page 34
provides a breakdown of the variances
in terms of the top three the pension
fund adjustment is
the largest area whether budgeted
expenditure for this was included but
the statutory adjustment to reverse it
to ensure
movements in the value of the pension
fund do not impact on the general fund
was there not included this was
highlighted
in november as part of the budget
monitoring process and it has been
corrected in this year's
budget as well so that will not be a
recurring item
the second largest the prior adjustment
relates to a creditor that was raised in
relation
to entries for the international
accountants down in 19
however the amount should have been
taken through the incoming expenditure
account
last year rather than as a creditor and
that's been identified as part of our
closure work
this year and that's been corrected and
will of course be subject
toward it and the final third largest
there is the vacancies
factor so there's an underspend in
salaries
due to holding on to vacancies which
naturally take time to recruit
in some instances and that's provided
an underspend for us past years have
also shown
uh underspends as well in relation to
shari's and the use of a vacancy factor
to recognize this in future years budget
may be appropriate so we don't continue
to have
an underspend in that area overall the
general fund balance has increased by
300 000 to 5.8
million and the underspend is 1.2
million which is uh similar to
past out terms
thank you miss leslie do members have
any questions
uh i think it was um
yeah okay thank you thank
thank you mr chairman um right i've only
got one query really
and i understood that all the works to
the letter center had been undertaken
and that all the future maintenance was
going to be and any works were going to
be undertaken by the
um and we've given them lots of uh
discounts and everything else due to
covid but i'm a bit surprised i would
have brought up with the working group
but i couldn't get there why
the um we've got 24
500 uh payment for the air handling unit
on page 36 and the table five and i'm
just a bit surprised i thought we'd
carried out all the works unless it was
one that was carried over it's like it
could be me that's wrong but i was a bit
surprised to see that one on there
mr holmes i i remember this coming up
earlier in the year so thank you yes
i believe that was a carry for there was
an item of uh air conditioning unit
which is on the top of the building
effectively that was still the council's
responsibility so this is the uh
this is the cost of putting that correct
in that
be absolutely right the rest of the
center is responsibility of places for
people
in terms of its maintenance so so if i
might have a supplementary are we still
paying for maintenance for something on
this i thought the last contract we got
it so we paid
nothing and that was the whole point
that we did them a cheap rent
i believe this is the end of life of
that piece of equipment so it's to
replace that equipment and then our
commitment is finished then because
it's renewed i think it was simply
because it was at end of life or towards
end of life
i'm just a bit i'm just a bit concerned
about the
terms of the contract that's why it just
seems really strange because normally
when you
see if something falls to bits you have
to replace it otherwise you get charged
it when you give up the lease that's i'm
just
a bit surprised by that we're still
paying
it it was something that came came
forward earlier this year it wasn't in
terms of
our expenditure so it has been agreed um
so yeah i think it's something that was
that was
at its end of life and that didn't need
to replace for safety reasons
cancer stem yeah thank you chair i just
wondered if i can ask mr leslie wouldn't
the auditors picked up the pension
deficit
and they understood the books
in regards to the 269 thousand pounds
one the or speaking
sort of on behalf of the audience i
guess the audit looks at accounts to
make sure that they are a true and fair
statement of accounts they don't look at
making sure it's 100 accurate in every
single transaction
and that's not what they do they make
sure it's true and fair and it's
materially correct
as well so there can be um
matters that aren't 100 but it's a
material and true and fair view of the
council which the audiences are
interested in and of course they look at
it this year
um as well so can i just come back
i think that's quite a large amount and
i'm a little bit surprised it's it's not
a grand or ten grand
it's a heck of a lot to be to be missed
and i think
i i can i know i haven't been um a
district councillor for very long but i
know pensions have been an issue and
raised
quite often at this council to make sure
people has enough money in that pension
fund
it's a massive massive problem um
so i'm just a little bit concerned thank
you jim i i think it turns out
it was a previous area wasn't it in
terms of the
of how that happened so fine it was just
an observation i think it's a lot of
money chairman
and so remiss of us as a council if we
don't question when there's 260 odd
thousand pounds yeah exactly
on behalf of available districts okay
thanks councillor don
any other questions yeah one of the
things that
uh i i know that we're looking at doing
is is to ensure that
as mr leslie referred to is to ensure
that we
are accounting as accurate as possible
um in future budget years and and to try
and create
create these these differences as as as
accurate as possible
um yeah and the good thing about it is
we're in a better financial position
than we initially thought yes i'd like
to say it's not a criticism of our
current team at all
and i'd also like to say that i'm really
happy and pleased that we're getting so
much information and it is accurate i
really do feel as though we've got a
fantastic
accounts team so please don't take it
no we do and i i said today that uh
i think we've got a very good set up now
in terms of how we're working together
in the working groups and
ensuring that you know that we we
operate throughout the year in terms of
looking at these things
um and i'd just like to thank mr portis
and mr leslie for the work that they do
and their teams for the work that they
do
okay uh so can i take
uh so the recommendations are opened on
that but all right
so the recommendations are uh that the
provisional outro position for 2021
financial year be noted
little two that the movement on the mark
reserves and appendix to be approved
that revenue commitments in appendix 3
be approved to be fought forward
to 21 22 that the capital commitment
rolls forward
into 2021-22 to be approved
do i have a second video for that please
councillor dwayne thank you very much
uh so uh can we agree that by ascent
please members thank you very much
so we now move on to agenda item
eight which is mid-year growth bids
found on pages
45-57 i think this is again
mr leslie and mr porteous to present the
report
thank so growths were kept to a minimum
when the budget was set
and as such further growth bids have
needed to come forward uh
during the year table one on page 45
shows the revenue growths which relate
to three posts the planning enforcement
offices are required to deliver the
agreed service standards
that were previously approved as part of
the policy and the operational
manager provides sufficient capacity
within the team
to fulfill their duties and
allow strategic priorities to be
engaged to
capital bids related to an investment
sorry two capital bids relate to
investors save initiative
regarding the gen g100 gym and the other
is a mower to replace the existing one
which is now beyond repair and
clearly needed to cut the grass in that
respect thank you thank you mr leslie
so i have to remember to remove the
recommendations first of all
uh say the recommendation has set out in
the reports as follows that the
revenue and capital growth bids at
appendix one and two
are respectively approved can i have a
second to please
so councillor durham thank you
councillor white
um thank you mr chairman and i was just
um
in curious with the mower um i
understood that we
paid it used to be livermore and i can't
think of a guy's name hat now who
mows the verges um
so why are we paying for more mowers
when we're subconsciously out and i also
raised at the last or the previous one
before last strategy resources that we
needed to price up in-house and pensions
and labour as opposed to subcontracting
and that doesn't appear to have come
forward now so i've not been on the ball
i do apologize
so i'm a bit surprised that we're just
spending more money when we haven't done
that um
financial report i don't know if i've
missed it maybe i've missed it
mr turns miss leslie thank you chairman
um so the parks team has a number of
items of equipment to carry out works
in-house itself they might be used at
cemeteries or on the parks and open
spaces
has a number of contracts as well some
of the contractors you mentioned who
grow do verge maintenance
so this is one of the pieces of
equipment that the council uses yourself
and probably in its cemetery sites
um the existing piece of equipment is 17
years old it's literally
um most fleets of change over seven or
eight years old we've run it
now for um 17 years um it's now
literally end of life so this is to
replace that piece of equipment
in terms of looking at the whole uh way
we operate as a parks team
um then that is something that stephen
butcher is looking at along with
peter clark but we haven't produced that
report yet but nonetheless
um we have still got services to deliver
um and yeah we're now at a point where
this this equipment has failed so it
doesn't allow us to just do the basics
at the moment
that's right you're happy with that i
don't know do you mike
it's not entirely because it's cash and
horse and we did ask for this to be
looked into so i'm a bit disappointed
there's no
not even any mention of it and i say i
haven't been well so i haven't been on
the ball
um but it's disappointing nonetheless i
i think yeah
with the pressures that the council and
the officers have been under especially
in that particular team
uh it's understandable that those those
particular things haven't been brought
forward
the key thing to remember about about
things like
mowing and things like that is we do we
we are making money from that in terms
of doing it in parishes and
i know for one of my parishes they they
chose more district council as their as
their supplier for doing this particular
work
so yeah there is the potential i think
to earn more money from this
that's my personal opinion uh counselor
durham
well all i can say chairman is if the
parks team have managed to nurse a ride
on mower for 17 years
then they have done extremely well
because i used to have to turn mine over
on a five-year basis and uh usually
after five years the
the the the graph for
cost of maintenance and replacement
tends to cross so they've done extremely
well
and 24 000 seemed like a lot of money
but that's probably about half of the
price of some of the machines that i
bought
cancer stuff yeah thank you chairman
i'll take on board what councilor white
said but i don't remember that actually
being agreed at a council meeting i
think i remember council white
suggesting it
but i i can't remember which which if it
was a working group or if it was a full
council meeting i can't remember
like you i do i am so sorry um but i
i i we can assure councillor white that
lots of things are being locked into
and the team is only a certain size at
the moment
and they're working their very best we
thought we have questioned about this
lawnmower
and i think yourself and myself got an
email tonight chairman
um because we were looking at a lawn
mower that was collecting grass because
we know we get so many complaints about
the grass just being left where it is
and people picking up the wet things and
throwing them each other etcetera
etcetera
and the reason given so why we weren't
going to have a collect on was other
reasons
were valid reasons but they are going to
look at it and they're going to bring a
proposal to council later on
so all i can ask chairman and members of
this committee is just to be patient
these things that members have brought
up in the past are being looked at
thank you chairman from my recollection
uh i think we were talking about
expenditure on these items at the
working group rather than that the
strategy resources committee
so i think that's where the discussions
took place councillor thompson
thank you chairman i think perhaps you
know the time to make sure this
this is looked at is before we issue any
more long or expensive contracts
as long as we've done it by then that's
really amazing
yeah thank you council thompson
councillor yeah thank you chair i'm i'm
very pleased to see these items
on the agenda to come forward this
evening i think that
we noted earlier on um there was a
surplus in the budget for
staff so this this goes somewhere to
deliver those services which is
is what we're about the lawn mower i
think is a very good price
again it's a it's an item of asset the
officers have looked deeply at it
it's not a cheap option but it's not an
expensive option it's a good option
so i think all of the things that have
been put in here have been been
scrutinized
and put forward in a very fair way to be
able to make a decision to support
services and i'm very pleased to do so
in council
and i've said it before and i'll say
again
earlier in the year i i was probably uh
more hesitant about some of these these
uh decisions and and employ
and yeah i have been persuaded and i'm
happy to agree with it and i think it's
yeah we do need to provide
uh these roles and and these things to
ensure that the council
works effectively can't say durham well
chairman yes
i was just going to echo what you're
saying in respect of the the
revenue items enforcement officers is
the one thing we desperately desperately
need
because that's one of the biggest
complaints we get from our parish
council so
um you know fill those positions as
quick as possible is what i would say
thank you
i'm sure mr holmes will do that
okay so can we agree these
recommendations by senate members
thank you very much
uh so we now come to a gender item nine
which is susta
supplementary estimates environments and
use of reserves uh first of october
2020 to the 31st may 2021 found on pages
57 260. mr leslie and mr portis
so environments and supplementary
estimates over a certain threshold are
required to come
to a committee and also
procurement exemptions we've had no
violence or subsidy
estimates requiring uh to be reported to
committee
but we have had procurement exemptions
and they are listed
there on page 58 paragraph 3.4.1
we have been impacted in on by covid to
a certain extent uh
and you'll see some of these coming
through in the exemptions that we've
been required to
put in place to deal with the copied
response for example
five lakes uh arena there the venue for
for the elections
is uh one of them thank you okay
uh so the recommendations that are set
out in the report are as follows
it's a little warned that the
procurement exemptions detailed
in section 3.4.1 be being noted
and that the drawdown reserves detailed
in section 3.5.2
of this report also be noted could i
have a second please
counselor sway are there any questions
or comments
counselors yeah thank you chair
um the 21 600 for five lakes
we won't we get that back do we not can
we not claim that back at all
yes we've used that for a variety of
elections and they are uh externally
funded mainly so we can reclaim the
costs
via the essex county uh elections uh
the police uh elections um as well so
yeah we'll be looking to reclaim well we
will be able to claim all that this
is uh just about the procurement
exemptions rather than it being a cost
to the council so
that's correct so it's just a movement
it's just because we need to follow our
procurement even though
it's externally funded we need to follow
our own procurement policies
uh and and that's following our
procurement policies so yeah it's
externally funded but we are
following our own procurement policies
so they're not costs to the council
in this case that they aren't but some
of them are
what i was actually trying to get at so
you i know what you're trying to what
you're saying to me but i wanted it to
be clear to everybody that that is not
going to be a cost to the council
that five legs that's right yep thank
you
any other questions okay
uh so can we um agree those
recommendations via sent
thank you very much members
and so we now move to agenda item 10
which is the a12
uh transfer to a120 widening while we
sort of just before i start doing that
there's 40s we'll be leaving
so i'll wait until you do
that's mrs good evening
and mrs longman do you want to come in
okay so we moved to it as i said a
gender item 10 which is the a12
chancered to a120 widening scheme
response to highways england public
consultation
on preliminary design this is found on
pages 61-77
and mrs long and the officer to the
strategy place is to present the report
mr longwood
yeah this is a national infrastructure
project
and it's to widen the a12 to
three lanes between the junction
19 forum interchange to
junction 25 and the marx tay
a120 interchange so the public
consultation
commenced on the 22nd of june and months
for eight weeks to the 16th of august
and this is for the preliminary design
the preferred group was
was set out in 2019
so members and officers have attended
all stakeholder meetings workshops and
member forums over the last year
and to work up the preliminary design
working with essex county council
highways and the other
local authority areas that this section
of the a12 falls in
we have raised the number of concerns
about the
the project and the preliminary design
modern district residents and businesses
rely on
local road connections to
connect connect to the a12
so prior to the public consultation
commencing essex county council wrote to
malden district council just to try and
highlight
our concerns before the
consultation commenced and that's in
appendix one the letter from councillor
kevin bentley to the leader
we respond the council responded on the
13th of may
setting out the council's concerns and
the missed opportunities
to the junction design options that were
being
presented
so obviously
the a12 is an important link in essex
and it is apparent the project will
improve journey times once on the a12
and reduce congestion on local roads and
when the a12 has had to close in the
past due to accidents
that the local red road network sees
that congestion
but we feel that the preliminary
designers missed the opportunity
to improve connections to the a12 from
within the malden district
and so we set that out in appendix um
too that was a letter from the
um mr paul dodson to andrew cook
county and so the the council's response
the draft response
appendix iii has um sort of
re-emphasized those concerns
that were set out
yep so so that that's in appendix 3 so
i've cross referenced everything to the
consultation brochure
in that draft response and to the public
consultation
thank you very much so the
recommendations which
are to council so they won't be voted
upon tonight
that the response to highways england
public consultation for the prime design
of a12 chelmsford to a120 widening
scheme
pending street is approved we'll have a
second of least councillor swain thank
you very much
are there any comments from members
the overall impression that i get is
regardless of what discussions have been
taking place
um involving the county council highways
england have just gone their own sweet
way and done whatever they
intended to do effectively as they even
admit in the
consultation really just leaving
es6 to try and make the best of a bad
job
first of all that's had the effect of
the
scheme will actually make
walden and cambridge and the district
less accessible
to quite weird network than before but
what i think it does point out is we
need to
expedite discussions with the county
council about what they
um what their future plans for the road
network are all around pedestrians
thank you council this week council
durham yeah thank you
um i agree with them councillor swain
and yes i don't think there's any doubt
that
this is going to improve things when
you're on the a12
the problem for us is when we've had to
get on to it
because obviously there is concern
particularly our voice concern about
uh the junction at hatfield pedro that
is bad now
um and it's with the closure of the
other um
exits it's going to be even worse but um
uh
as councillor swain says i think
highways england are
you know it's done and dusted from their
point of view anyway
um but i think there needs to be
mitigation measures
uh from the county council in relation
to those junctions but we we shall see
yeah and i know the county council feel
the same as we do about
half of purple so it is a joint uh
impression that it is not
fit for purpose and has not been
designed well uh and the fact that
there's still that mold and road and the
mini roundabout is still going to be
the main route to the a12 is not
acceptable
in terms of that route from from that
part of malden obviously as
a member of a ward that represents the
north of the district
there are swings around about me and the
a12 will go through part of
of my ward it's the one of the bits of
the
moulton that actually touches the a12 so
yeah there will be improvements in terms
of
some of the congestion in great braxton
but there are
there are negatives as well and yeah
it's it's it's great that this is coming
forward but the links to it
aren't on it aren't good the the one
benefit i think is the new junction at
inwoof
because the bro all the traffic from
tiptree will go straight down to the a12
rather than coming through braxton and
causing all that congestion
at river north end and that is one of
the
rivenal end and that the removal of that
which is one of the main accident black
spots
on on the a12 has only got to benefit um
so hopefully we can together with with
essex put pressure on that
yeah and with brain treatise our council
which is where people comes under
um that to get a better link
to the a12 from malden we can only hope
for that
thank you mr longman so that will go to
full council in the letter's got to be
by august the 16th is that right
it's just one of those unfortunate
situations where the the um
committee cycle and the um and the
public consultation
dates don't quite line up so so the
recommendation will be for council to
ratify
to ratify ratify the the response okay
you're recommended okay so we're happy
to
send that letter in and then for that to
be written by the full council in
september
okay thank you very much
the lights on
they can come and do my kitchen and
thank you very much jackie
okay so we now move on to agenda item 11
which is the welcome back fund
found on pages 79 to 82
and this is going to be presented by mrs
button who is strategy policy and
communication manager
thank you chairman do the members in
front of me mind if i pull my mask down
that's fine
so this report informs members of the
welcome back fund
um it sets out the principles in terms
of the approach and the engagement we
wish to carry out and how we're going to
defray this fund members will be aware
of the work undertaken
last year under the high street task
force framework
and funding secured from the reopening
high streets safely fund
this work was an important part of our
response to the covid pandemic
and our economic response and recovery
plan and this aims to maintain
safety and to help our high streets
thrive
the welcome back fund builds on the
reopening high street safely fund
and funding is available to be utilized
before the end of march 2022
this report outlines our approved
welcome back fund action plan
our approach to stakeholder engagement
and our projects
and project prioritization it's
important to note
that owing to the tight time scales and
our wish to engage with local
stakeholders
clearly in line with any guidance we are
progressing this activity at pace
and in advance of the recruitment of a
lead specialist
as detailed in this report it's worth
noting
in the summary of key issues in section
3
it states what is in scope and what is
out of scope
in terms of how this money can be spent
and then from 3.7 to 3.13 it breaks down
how we plan to apportion the fund
this is fun so the recommendations are
set out in report
are little one that members note the
previous ongoing
work to support our high streets visitor
economy and business community
and the appointment of the fixed term
post of a lead specialist
prosperity a little too that members
endorse
the welcome back fund engagement
approach and principles
and then little three that members
endorse the welcome back prioritization
principles
could i have a second or for that please
counsellous wayne thank you
do you have any questions at all
so i saw councillor lagan first
thank you chair um i've got a bit of a
problem with this
it seems strange to to not want to grab
hold of as much
money as possible but my worry is that
we
will produce plans but no actions
um we've got so many master plans which
we've yet to deliver upon
and it just seems to me that my concern
is that we'll put
a lot of work into recruiting this post
developing something and then we're not
going to have the the way with all to
deliver what we said we're going to
we're going to do in the collection
exercise when you look at the
central area master plan lower high
street the reset recovery
and other open acronyms i can't really
remember you know
it's um i don't know it just seems a bit
uncomfortable that
we're not going to get what we want out
of this because it's such a short period
of time
and also to do this effectively the
person who would have to be in that post
would have to know
the high street and the town of the
culture like the back of their hand
so i have some concerns and there's also
language about what's a realm
within it on page 80 there was a phrase
sorry let's
just procrastinate fraction but i'm
going to get this right
about 3.3 the guidance is extensive but
the following explicitly out of scope
activity that provides no additionality
understand the others but i'm not really
sure what that actually means
so just on the first point um just to
say actually agree with a lot of what
you're saying
i don't think any officer would disagree
with you yeah in terms of there is a lot
that we
have set out to try and achieve as a
local authority and obviously we only
have um certain amount resource to
deliver
and it's very hard for this fund the
scope sets out
that and it's very common for any
government fund
as part of the scope because they
recognize local authorities don't have
the resource sitting there waiting to do
that work um
that it can be spent on the resource to
get the work done
but recognising this is a real tight
time scale and we do
have a welcome back action plan already
approved it's written it's ready to go
we do need to quickly resource so we can
take action
and interviews for that post will be
taking place the first week of august
and then we hopefully should be ready to
get cracking
um so but completely agree is a lot
and we are wanting to go out to
businesses
to parish clerks sense of place
and hand out an e-form and printed form
so that people can
put forward their ideas so we are
expecting to receive
a lot of ideas to support how we ensure
the high street thrives so it is a big
ask but we
it would be a shame to waste the
opportunity and not to at least try and
spend it
um in the time frame that we've been
given so on the second point
additionality it just means
within the scope of it you can't spend
it on funds that doesn't provide ever
any form of value or provide any sort of
um
outcome so it's we could just spend it
on whatever we like you know we could
go and spend it on our new lawn mowers
um
something like that you know and of
course that doesn't bring additionality
in terms of the scope of the fund so
that's all that means
council are going to be happy with those
okay so cancel stamp
yeah thank you chairman um
i also have concerns i think i've raised
with you
um i would like to know how tightly
this person when we apply them if we
employ them is going to be managed
and i think it could be if we're not
careful it could be a
um a non-fruitful i think and when
you're a post rather
i mean i'm i'm getting a little bit fed
up sometimes with hot air rather than
action
and i think miss button and i have had a
conversation about this and she
has assured me that it won't be the case
in this instance but
it would be remiss of me not to explain
my concerns to
the rest of this committee i think it is
a good a good way of um spending some
money if we've got it but you've got to
get out there
can't just sit behind a desk and you
can't just make the phone calls you've
actually got to get out into the
communities
and start speaking to businesses and
dare i say not just the favorite few
you know you've got to look at what's
out there don't just do malden and
some of burnham do telling them do
southminster you know do
everything in this district um and if
you know i'm sure i don't know who's
going to manage this person and forgive
me and maybe should know
but as long as it has got some
accountability
and i also would like it to come back at
on a i don't know quarterly basis to
snr and pgno so we can actually look at
the achievement so what has actually
been
been achieved and what is going to be
achieved because i wouldn't want it to
be wasted it is a welcome back fund
and i think there are businesses that
have been on their knees and you've got
you're going to have new startups as
well chairman
and i think it's important that this
money is well spent because it's a large
pot of money
and i think we really do need to spend
it wisely chairman
and i'm assured i'm sure miss button
will come back and uh
hopefully she can reassure me that the
person that they employ
is going to be somebody who actually
does it gets off their bottoms as i said
at council the other day rather than
speaks about
it and then i'll be more than happy
thank you jeff spartan will you have a
tight reign on this person then
absolutely um and and actually in terms
of the role
um because of it being a lead specialist
that would sit within service delivery
so their function is to deliver is to
take something through to action
it's not to go out horizon scanning and
gathering data
and draw up a strategy it's actually
about being active
and making sure that they're using the
resources around them to get that money
spent
and what is really important about this
is that we claim it retrospectively
so we do the activity we claim it and we
have to report on it
so you know if we don't do this we're
not getting the money so um that
the real this really is pressured
okay that's the swain yes thank you
chairman
this is money that we have sort of given
to use for these purposes
although i don't think many of them are
particularly applicable
um particularly four and five and five
i'm not sure what it means
and the one that is relevant is number
six um
and uh but otherwise i i think spending
most of this money on
on a post that's going to largely
produce communications material
information is
probably not a very good use of public
resources
um if we do use it then i think i would
like to see
it used to produce something concrete
rather than just intangible information
flows
um particularly bearing in mind this
question of um
improving the position of the high
street
and i would like to see some of these
funds used
for short short-term um
renting of vacant premises um
such they would be then available to any
of any business small business community
group or whatever
um to conduct um pop-up
shop activity or art and craft displays
or whatever
um as an additional contribution to
attract people industry
or conversely to use it
at an appropriate location to
help promote the idea that's been
floated in the um
uh climate change working group for
some location where people can
operate recycling repairing upcycling
activities
and which would then contribute to other
aspects of what we're trying to achieve
where how can this money be used and
allocated could it be used on things
like that
so um within the action plan it
the first thing you have to do first is
ask businesses where they would like
that money spent
um and and make sure that you know we
prioritize
their needs however as councillors wayne
has said there are those opportunities
and
as officers we've had exactly that
conversation about all of those ideas
that you've
you've shared um because it's about
utilizing the high street in it in a
different way that
enables people to access it use it and
help it to thrive
in a time when it's competing with
online shopping
and we do understand it's not just about
putting out communication materials it's
about
very quickly getting out and asking what
people's ideas are
and making sure that spaces that are not
utilized
are used maybe differently and through
the ideas
and feedback that we've had and not just
you know a quick and easy fix yeah i
think that's where
using things like town and parish
councils as well will help because
they're the ones that know
what needs to be done and where there
might be a requirement um
yeah we're not shopkeepers member
officers aren't shopkeepers
and and it's not the role of the council
to do that
but if we can encourage it as you're
saying then that that will be of benefit
so those things could come forward the
council's way
absolutely councillor morris
thank you very much mr chairman um
official government figures show that
covid is now comparable
with the flu in both mortality rates
and transmissibility i'd just like to
know
will this fund be used to revitalize the
businesses rather than restrict
and further damage them with scare
mongering and unnecessary restrictions
that will reduce consumer confidence
thank you i think some of that is
relevant some of it isn't relevant uh
so um would you like to answer the bits
that are relevant so we're
definitely expecting um towards the end
of july a
outbreak containment management plan
from government and
um i'm not going to speak on behalf of
the government that's not my place but i
know
there is fresh thinking around
what we do with um the stickers the sign
posting the things that are in place at
the moment
we also recognize i know it's been
mentioned before you know some of that's
getting tatty and a bit worn and
actually we'd like to do something about
that
so this does provide an opportunity this
fund provides us an opportunity to say
where is this best spent if it's not
best spent on stickers and sign
posting based on the given time
um where is it best spent what we do
have to be conscious of though
is that come the end of this year before
the end of march we may see a third wave
and another set fourth wave yeah another
set
of guidelines may come in and we may be
expected to
adapt and utilize that fund to respond
but our primary focus is absolutely
spending it on making sure that
more people visit the high streets we're
giving them reasons to come and spend
time
and to interact with businesses to help
them survive
but we need to go out and ask them what
they need us to do first and that's the
bit we need to act on very quickly
supplementary place check yes we never
scared everyone like this with the flu
though did we
say it something that's not really
relevant to moles of district council
and
and in terms of the uh information
that's been provided by
government we've all got different views
on that what we have to do
is ensure that some it is a fact that
the flu
is comparable with kovid it's so we're
not we're not here to
debate that no no no i'm not i'm not
debating that it's just that you know
bringing it bringing that to the
forefront we never did all this
rubbish with the flu did we i appreciate
that so yeah we will ensure that this
money is spent
in the right way to help businesses and
support businesses and and to divert the
high street in in the right way
and thank you very much mr chairman
thank you uh council white
um thank you miss john um surprisingly i
find myself agreeing with cancer lagging
actually
um and i have a few questions as the
debate's gone on
is this just for the high street or is
it for all businesses because it seems
to be morphing into high street only
which is fair enough of it is but i read
it that it was all businesses
and the other thing is i think some of
it's crossing over with the commercial
manager
with some of the things they're looking
for and i think that could be undertaken
by that officer and i had reserves about
the officer because i don't think it's
ever got more income than what his
salary is that's another issue
it might have changed now um but and i
just think a little bit disappointing
that we've
raised all we were given 185 000 in
funding 180 000 in funding
but most of it's going to go on salaries
and there's only 55 000 left
and i think we need to be very careful
about the objectives and the
achievements we want to
get to rather than just blowing it
because the moment we've got no idea
where it's going
and i just don't want to waste all the
money um
slowly asking every business what they
want we need to come up with some
strategic decisions on what we think
needs to be done then consult the
businesses
and if it is district-wide we need to
consult more because i've asked
businesses in my
district if they've been contacted never
said no and i said do you know about the
coveted funding and they said no
nobody's ever written to us
so you know we're charging them business
rates or they're exempt from business
rates so we we do have a database to
contact them i think we need to but
you know for me we shouldn't keep buying
all this eu money um
on on wages and we should try and get
more bang for our buck than just
a paper trail you know we need something
effective and 55 000 is not a lot of
money it's not going to go very far
especially when the salary is more than
what we've got to actually spend
so how are we going to achieve this
because it looks to me like again we've
kind of got the cart there and the horse
doesn't know where it's going
i'm not meaning to be negative it's just
my concern reading through
because the other thing is under 3.3
it's all about
securing additional funding well
you know we've got we've got to work out
what we're doing and should the
commercial manager also be looking at
funding and not just this particular
specialist i don't know
just i think i think in terms of so i
might
have a little bit of input uh in terms
of commercial management in terms of the
commercial projects that's separate to
this particularly
commercial manager is focused on on what
we do within the council in terms of our
own commercial projects
in terms of the prosperity element in
terms of the strategy it is about
ensuring that we help
businesses and i i completely agree with
you councillor white
it is very very difficult and there
isn't a lot of money there
and it is a district-wide thing so it is
open to
all businesses across the district uh
but there's anything else you want to
add at all yeah i mean
if we don't the officers don't disagree
with you it is the structure of the
council and that's the role that would
pertain to that activity however the the
joint remaining
remaining fund so from both the welcome
back fund
and the rhss one the reopening high
street safety fund
um the the balance at the moment is 145
558 so it's approximately
60 000 pounds when you include all the
on top costs for the salary
nine months of that would be paid for
from the fund
and a further three months is paid from
the council's corporate delivery fund
so it's not utilizing all of the fund um
recognizing
the significance of that salary which we
absolutely do
um the role doesn't just defray that the
funds itself
um it will be in in light of the fact
that
members will be aware that we don't have
an economic development function
as some other local authorities do um
we were moved to that um in in recent
years
to undertake the work um it does go
beyond the format the formal remap sorry
remit
of our existing resources so we've
scoped out what that role can do
so as well as um defraying the funds
it's making sure
that they are speaking to be actively
going out and speaking to businesses
supporting um the partnership activities
and talking to all businesses not just
the high street
um and making sure that it supports the
visitor economy
and ensures um that the liaison with all
the groups and the partnerships that
we've got
are are hearing about this because
you're absolutely right there are lots
of people we've got 3500 registered
businesses
and and that's our concern is if they're
not hearing about this
then they've not they've not been part
of it so we've got to act quickly
do you know the the level of role
does demand that kind of salary if you
go out to the market so
that that's the the amount it will
consume
counselor are you happy with that so
what is the actual amount of funding
that we've actually got
available because i got confused there
again i was like i thought it was 180
000 and it was 60 000
on we'd already spent down to 145 then
there was 60 on
wages so what's left we had 185 yep
we've now got 145 yet we spent
10 000 on on spending 10 000
communication
15 000 on something else which i can't
remember the top of my head
um am i thinking okay so far which then
leaves us
uh with that with the salary and then
about about 50 000
it is the estimate isn't it to be spent
across local businesses
yeah so you know it could that's the
thing it's it's being able to go out to
businesses and
asking for their ideas first and
foremost the ideas that we get back
might say
that actually we need to eat into a
chunk of that ten thousand that other
fifteen thousand that's allocated
because they come up with a brilliant
idea and we shouldn't waste that
opportunity
but what we've had to do is an early er
guesstimate is say
we think this is how this this would be
apportioned
but we absolutely shouldn't ignore a
really good idea
comes through that that money is then
prioritized
so i think the only concern i have is
that if my math in my head is right
which it probably isn't if we've got 55
000 was that work out 15 pounds of
business or something if 150 if you've
got three and a half thousand businesses
so it's nearly all gone in wages and and
the problems i see in my ward is
people say well how come you keep
getting all this money and we don't get
anything
and i'm like oh well well it's all gone
on wages and i'm like
um i never know quite how to answer that
one that was you know that that's it's
just what you hear on the ground is that
the the customers don't see it they just
get charge rates
it is it is a very difficult situation
and and i think we all feel the same
about this particular thing i think
we're all of the same mindset however
if we don't have this person to to
fulfill this role the money won't get
out at all
so we do need the person to be able to
put you to to
you know to allocate the money into yeah
and i said
part of me sees this as part of the
future this isn't this this should be
to me this is this is a future thing and
it's something that we can build upon
in future years and also one of my
views is in terms of the council in
terms of resourcing is we need to look
at how good resources
for the future and whether we've got the
right resources in the right places at
the moment
and i don't think we do and that's if i
could just come back and comment is that
that's uh you know what we're sort of
saying in terms of the
not having an economic development team
in place
if we had that today this could be given
to them straight away and we'd be doing
it
today yeah so that's the difficulty we
face cancer staff
thank you chair a couple of things um
when this is called a welcome back fund
yeah so so you know businesses may have
turned around and said what we're doing
for them as a council
um this is this is purely based on
welcome back after the code but if you
look at it it splits
into those different sections so we have
to look at it for what it's actually
intended for
and and talking about a particular
post or a particular manager i think is
is is ill-advised i don't particularly
like about speaking about officers
in that vein the commercial manager was
employed under the transformation the
transformation has taken place
from the previous administration and we
are and that's where we are
what we're now looking at is actually
looking where the gaps have appeared
and we do know that there's a disconnect
from the commercial manager and and the
role
that that position has fulfilled doesn't
actually
fit nicely within the organization as it
stands and
as i've said before we are bringing
things back to council and we are
looking at
um coming back to council most probably
to ask for additional positions or maybe
reorganizing something
um but i suggest miss but i don't if
anybody saw today
havering was featured on the 6 30 news
and about how much they've regenerated
and
it was absolutely inspirational there
was a young gentleman on there who'd got
mental health issues
and they had actually incorporated
things under their high street so it's
not just i think we really need to be
careful we're not going to just go
narrow-minded so everybody just thinks
it possibly is chairman
a high street it's not and that's that's
where i'm
confident that this person will sit
under
miss button mr holmes and we have
already discussed this at great length
and i think
the the areas that we want to look at
is greater and wider and i think i've
made it quite clear we can't just do
something
very narrow chairman we've got to
actually include everybody what we we
can include and that could be
what council swain said you know we
could look at maybe um have it paying
some rent for six months or something if
that's appropriate
or that could come after this first
piece of work this is the initial step
and it's called the welcome back fund i
think boris johnson was it yesterday or
today
he did his leveling up fund there's lots
of things coming out now
and we as a council need to make sure
we're looking forward
um to actually as far as i'm concerned
embrace it
it's not perfect but then i don't think
anything is thank you
thank you council thank you
um chairman
i don't think the officer meant to lead
us in this direction
and you alluded to it yourself our
biggest issue is the fact that we
haven't got an economic development
manager or team
even and i think it was the worst days
work this council did to
get rid of that function we put we are
probably the only district in essex that
doesn't have that function and i suspect
we're one of the very few
districts towns or boroughs across the
entire country
that doesn't have an economic
development function
certainly having been for the last year
been
a deputy to econom economic development
at his county
it was a real issue dealing across the
districts
it was an issue when we came to malden
because there was nobody in that
position
and uh so i i would implore
the the leader and the council to to
look at this again
because it is absolutely critical
you know perhaps it wasn't quite so
critical when that decision was made
although i doubt it somewhat and it's
been brought to the fore by covid
obviously
that economic development is an
absolutely
vital function of all local authorities
and as i said
we were we were sorely mistaken when we
did away with that
um so you know please let's i would hope
to have that renewed
yeah and yeah one of the things that
that the council now needs to look at is
is what
is the what is the future what's the
council need what's the structure and
those are the sort of things that
that hopefully as a as a whole we will
be having discussions around about
what what does that our council need to
be in terms of the next 10 15 years
to ensure that we are sustainable as a
council but we're also making sure that
modern district council is sustainable
as well
uh council lager jeff thank you for
letting me come back
um so just so i'm really clear with so
this this will help create a vision that
we can live into
something that's tangible and
deliverables will come out of that
and two questions one you said mentioned
earlier
some of the money has maybe already been
spent
um and the second part just reassurance
for me is that
so you'll you'll you'll be managing this
and have the responsibility on a
day-to-day basis for the resource
so due to the role being a lead
specialist that will sit in richard
holmes is there in service delivery but
i will be
managing closely managing them and
working with them
to make sure that that works being done
and reported on
but absolutely the role sits within
service delivery so that they can
um focus on taking it through to action
and not
not um being set within the strategy
structure
of the organization but no i will i will
be working very very closely with them
thank you
mr holmes did you want to have some
input thank you just to echo that so the
uh the actual
uh senior specialist will report to my
senior specialist manager
who will be looked after other senior
specialists on a functional level
absolutely working hand in hand with
georgina and her team so that sort of
direction around technical direction
around the um the work that they need to
do will be very much hand-in-hand so yes
that's how it will work
counselor can i just remind everybody
that i think mr leslie may need to help
me how much have we paid out business
grant
to support our businesses i mean i know
it's come from government but how much
have we paid
it's around 26.6 million pounds that
we've paid out directly to
local businesses yeah thank you
can i make an amendment to the
recommendations when you come you can
would you like to do it now if you could
um can i actually do a little
a one v not a little for a one fee
can i actually ask that um included in
the recommendations that a report goes
back to snr and pg a please
okay i think that would happen anyway is
that correct well it doesn't say on
recommendations chair okay
uh so do you want the do you want the
objectives come to s
r and the results go to p s s
r can come i don't know um i don't know
could be guided by um
miss button here quarterly or every two
months or whenever you've got a meeting
actually we could have an update and
then pg
a could be um three months or six months
or something
yeah it's just to actually to make sure
that we can actually
make sure that doing so so the project
as it were
comes to snr and then that we make sure
that we look at
governing the results but chairman not
to hold it up
no no no we don't want the officer to
spend time just producing reports
okay cancer sway yes
conscious of the time looking at this um
it says the
this has to be the um money has to be
defeated by the
march of next year it's very short time
scale to get things
spent although presumably what is spent
could
in fact um actually have its effect
after that day um and i think following
from what
council stand was saying we want perhaps
um
an idea of what kind of things are
planned
as soon as as soon as um there is a
program
yeah of action um monitoring can come
afterwards but
we really need to know just what sort of
things
are going to be involved in this okay
because obviously somebody needs to get
on with it
yeah well obviously the person who's
reported will have to produce
a plan and that plan can then come to us
okay uh so with that amendment uh that
uh the plans will come to snr and that
the work
is reviewed uh i probably it's because
the time skills there'd have to be
again maybe every four months to pgna
so on on little two and that the other
amendment uh and the recommendations
stay the same
and can we agree that virus sent members
and do i need to second that amendment
yeah so could we have a second for
council stamps councillor dora
okay thank you very much
so we now move on to agenda item 12 and
that is any of the any other items of
business that the chairman of the
committee decides are owed
and there are none so in moot item
number 13
which is the exclusion of the public and
press and to resolve that under section
100a
brackets for the local government act
1972
the public be excluded from the meeting
for the following items of business on
the grounds that
they involve the light disclosure of
exempt information
as defined in paragraph 3 on part 1 of
the schedule 12a to the act
and that this satisfies the public
interest
can i have a seconder for that please
cancel this way
so we will just now wait until the live
feed
you